if men should be more emotional and show
their emotions more no again there may
have been a time in American culture
when perhaps there was too much emphasis
on stoicism for men that's not the case
at all anymore that's not that's not
what men are encouraged to do where
actually the issue is that men are far
too encouraged to be emotional there's
almost no emphasis on stoicism when
there should be part of being a man and
part of the service that a man can
provide society and especially his
family and his marriage is the ability
to carry burdens with silent dignity and
to carry them with strength being able
to carry a burden on your own silently
like Society needs men to do that women
need men to do that women want men to do
that